ciao a tutti non preoccupatevi non
dovrete leggerlo se serve solo a me come
guida
oggi io cercherò di raccontarvi la mia
esperienza di come l'azienda in cui
lavora da 12 anni ha cambiato il suo
modo di gestire la propria strategia in
questo nuovo mondo
la prima evidenza è che il mondo è
sempre cambiato oggi cambia in modo
diverso cambia maniera molto più veloce
una volta cambiamenti erano lenti si
scopriva la ruota e per qualche milione
di anni si rimaneva consolidare la
scoperta della ruota si scopriva la
lampadina per qualche centinaia di anni
si consolidava oggi come potete vedere
sta sempre di più aumentando la
frequenza di innovazione e scoperte
questo fa sì che ci sia un'accelerazione
che dall'innovazione cioè scopro con
solido scopro con solido si parta si
passa una filosofia di crescita tutti i
giorni c'è qualcosa di nuovo e non c'è
più il consolidamento di questa scoperta
ma la condivisione è una cosa bellissima
perché permette di far saltare
tantissime regole
la seconda evidenza è che il mondo
imperfetto
questo ci rende anche molto più
tranquilli nel gestire un'azienda in un
mondo imperfetto sai che è molto più
importante il tempo della perfezione
noi dobbiamo investire il 20 per cento
nel nostro tempo per arrivare a vere
l'ottanta per cento dei risultati perché
il resto del 20 per cento dei risultati
lo potremo solo raggiungere ed è
impossibile perché non c'è la perfezione
con l'altro 80 per cento quindi è molto
più importante di fare che vivere nella
perfezione la terza evidenza è che la
differenza fa valore
siamo in un sistema che tutti i giorni
escono nuovi prodotti tutti i giorni vi
vengono offerti nuovi servizi tutti i
giorni nuove applicazioni quella che
sarà attenzionata da voi che prenderà la
vostra attenzione e quella diversa dalle
altre
quindi questi tre elementi sono
importantissimi per l'azienda e per
poter costruire le loro strategie
il primo è capire che dovrà sempre
evolversi
il secondo è che più importante il fare
della perfezione e il terzo è che il
valore dell'azienda è quello di essere
diversa dalle altre
da queste tre evidenze passiamo a quelli
che sono invece quattro punti per
cambiare una strategia per cambiare la
strategia dell'azienda
il primo punto che secondo me più
importante
ero messo primo proprio perché poi anche
gli altri conseguono questo punto è che
le aziende oggi devono mettere le
persone al centro che l'azienda quando
studiato economia
mi ha fatto ho insegnato che
l'imprenditore tra i fattori produttivi
i soldi all'epoca si chiamava la terra
che vuol dire l'impresa azienda dei
macchinari e la forza lavoro
l'imprenditore deve organizzare questi
tre fattori per raggiungere l'obiettivo
dell'azienda
oggi questa cosa non funziona più perché
in questo mondo così veloce
se non si è in grado di trovare il modo
per stare al passo con i tempi essere
protagonisti di questo cambiamento sia
morti è sempre più veloce il mercato
dell'azienda
l'unico modo per riuscire a essere
almeno veloci come l'azienda se non
addirittura essere noi protagonisti di
questo cambiamento e mettere le persone
al centro proprio perché le persone
hanno questa capacità di evolversi ogni
giorno i soldi per definizione sono
oggettivi i soldi non si evolvono sono
sempre un dato
la fabbrica ai macchinari la tecnologia
evolve ma in maniera molto più lenta di
quello che invece richiede il mercato
le persone possono nel loro lavoro
quotidiano
cambiare e adeguarsi al mercato
adeguarsi a quella che è la nuova così
visione della mobilità di un'azienda
quindi da un mondo dinamico a un mondo
statico il mondo dinamico dell'azienda
era quello in cui si inventava un
prodotto lo si perfezionava e poi lo si
continuava a produrre all'infinito
portando a casa quello che erano le
risorse oggi non funziona così oggi in
un'azienda bisogna che tutte le volte
che si fa il processo venga rivisto per
migliorarlo e per renderlo più
efficiente
questo fa sì che ogni volta che
nell'azienda si ci si sveglia la mattina
sempre nella nella fabbrica bisogna
arrivare dicendo cercherò di fare meglio
rispetto quello che ho fatto il giorno
prima anche nella nostra vita è così io
sono cresciuto in cui mi è stato detto
scegli la tua scuola perché con quello
che imparerai passerai tutto il resto
della tua vita lavorativa a sfruttare
quello che ho imparato nei primi anni
della tua vita
e poi se sei fortunato avrà gli ultimi
anni in cui andrà in pensione
che è molto simile alla filosofia
dell'azienda in cui fai un lavoro
momento iniziale in cui sviluppi un
prodotto e poi per il resto della tua
vita aziendale lo sfrutti io devo
studiare lavoro sfruttando quello che ho
studiato e poi godo con la pensione oggi
non funziona più
oggi il mondo è talmente in evoluzione
le informazioni che grazie alla
rivoluzione digitale arrivano nelle
nostre aziende nella nostra casa nella
nostra vita fa sì che io devo
dimenticare anzi quello che ho imparato
perché ogni giorno devo imparare
qualcosa di nuovo
quando mi viene chiesto che cosa posso
far fare a mio figlio io ti dico non
importa l'importante è che il suo figlio
in fare tutti i giorni del resto della
sua vita imparare qualcosa di nuovo
perché altrimenti sarà obsoleto dopo
neanche la fine del ciclo
se oggi inizi in un istituto tecnico a
vedere come funziona una macchina a
controllo numerico facilmente alla fine
del quinto anno quel sistema che ti
hanno insegnato e già obsoleto quindi la
cosa importante è capire che tutti i
giorni
bisogna imparare questo sia come persona
e quindi mettendo le persone al centro
dell'azienda è fondamentale che chi
lavora in azienda abbia questa visione
di continuare a mettersi alla prova
sia l'azienda stessa non deve credere
che il suo sia un prodotto perfetto
1 perchè non esiste la perfezione due
perché facilmente sul mercato nel giro
di pochissimo
ma non parliamo di anni parliamo di
quadrimestri mesi
arriverà qualcosa sul mercato che è
meglio del tuo
la seconda cosa siccome importantissima
in azienda è valorizzare gli errori noi
viviamo in un sistema che l'hard rock
che l'errore viene punito
strano io sono cresciuto sono nato ho
imparato a camminare cadendo bambino
cade 600 volte prima di trovarla
equilibrio per camminare
ho imparato a parlare blaterando e tutte
le volte che cadeva e blaterava i miei
genitori mi dicevano bravo continua così
allora perché se ho imparato a fare due
cose difficilissime che sono camminare e
parlare sbagliando da quando entrò nella
scuola
il mio errore viene punito io passo
ho passato la mia età scolare con il
timore di fare un errore scrivere libro
con 2 b
erano tre nel tema io sono dislessico
scritto tutta la vita libri con 2 b ea
senzacca questo mi ha creato uno stress
fortissimo su il fare perché il fare
implica la possibilità di sbagliare se
io vengo punito sul mio errore
cosa faccio se invece riusciamo a capire
che l'errore è il sistema di
apprendimento
se riusciamo a capire che la scienza è
progredita e progredisce a
approssimazione di errore perché in un
mondo come quello attuale in cui non
siano variabili in cui tutto il giorno è
diverso dal giorno prima
l'unica cosa da fare è io provo se
funziona bene lo faccio diventare mia
conoscenza se non funziona
ho commesso un errore evidenzia
all'interno dell'azienda che ho commesso
un errore
prendo con l'esperienza facendola
diventare miu miu
so che quella cosa è sbagliata che vuol
dire non la devo replicare
provo in un altro modo questo è anche
molto importante come dicevo prima per
il fare perché legato all'errore c'era
paura legata alla paura c'è il blocco se
vogliamo un'azienda innovativa
un'azienda sempre in evoluzione
dobbiamo per primo fare avere persone
che sono al centro che non hanno paura
di commettere errori perchè altrimenti
non facciamo niente di nuovo nel momento
che commettono un errore devono avere
l'umiltà sia alle persone ma sia
l'azienda stessa di ammettere di averlo
fatto in modo che sia all umiltà lo dico
agli altri
io non ho l'umiltà lo nascondo e questo
diventa il vecchio errore in cui non
serve a niente
avendo l'umiltà io posso dire a tutti i
miei collaboratori guardate che ho
commesso un errore posso crescere come
know how quindi con le conoscenze
all'interno dell'azienda
il terzo punto è la crescita dei talenti
in azienda o 50 persone ciò che il mondo
imperfetto quindi so che queste 50
persone non possono essere tutte
perfette
cosa succede e se quando mi arriva
davanti una persona
io cerco i suoi difetti e l'inizio di
allora tu sei timido e non parla in
inglese
tutto quello che è la serie dei suoi
difetti questa persona la xvi disco e
soprattutto a me il fatto di vedere solo
i suoi difetti
serve poco perché se io voglio che
quella persona diventi utile per la mia
azienda devo capire qual è il suo valore
qual è il suo talento stessa cosa per la
mia valutazione dell'azienda
io so che la mia azienda imperfetta e so
che ho delle cose negative e delle cose
positive
cerco di avere buona idea di come
l'azienda delle cose negative le
distingue il 2 quale strutturali e quale
tecniche quali strutturali sono siamo
una piccola azienda nel cuneese
la nostra sorgente è sul monte pigna
rispetto ad alcune aziende che sono
nella piana e hanno molta più facilità
raggiungere l'autostrada quella neanche
di negatività strutturale io non potrò
mai risolverla non posso prenderla
sorgente metterla in mezzo alla pianura
accetto di avere quel difetto una
negrita negatività tecnica e che nel mio
ufficio parlano male l'inglese non
l'accetto perché so che essendo tecnica
la posso migliorare cosa faccio mi
organizzo perché nel mio ufficio si
facciano corsi d'inglese
ma quello su cui io guardo vado a porre
il mio focus è cosa so fare bene perché
se io mi concentro su quello che so fare
bene ma c'è la differenza e abbiamo
detto che le aziende prodotti sono
scelti per la differenza che hanno
rispetto agli altri semi concentrarsi
solo nelle cose che non so fare e tutti
i miei competitor si concentrassero
nelle cose che non sanno fare a fermo
delle aziende standard tutte uguali
perché tutti saremo bravi a fare le cose
che non erano un capace far prima ma
nessuno è stato in grado di far crescere
il proprio talento
questo vale soprattutto per le persone
se un'azienda vedo una persona timida e
vedo una persona agitata già ho
sbagliato perché in un caso dovrà vedere
una persona riflessiva e nell'altro caso
dovrei vedere una persona
sapendo qual è il suo talento cioè che
la persona riflessiva appunto la
capacità di essere più concentrata sui
numeri più concentrata sulle cose che di
do invece la persona energetica magari
una persona molto brava a comunicare in
azienda la mia responsabilità di
amministratore delegato e prendere la
persona brava e riflessiva gli faccio
fare ravoni lavori su cui puoi esprimere
questo talento che vuol dire magari la
contabilità l'analisi dei dati la
persona che energetica una persona che è
sempre in movimento
mi farò fare la gente il venditore
quindi riuscire a evidenziare come
valore aggiunto
la valorizzazione degli errori e la
crescita del talento delle persone fa sì
che l'azienda si è sempre in grado di
stare al passo con quello che è il
cambiamento del mercato
ultima ma veramente importantissima che
oggi le aziende devono essere aperte
la tendenza delle aziende che
sviluppavano un prodotto e continuavano
a produrlo la stessa maniera per fare i
soldi del vecchio mercato di statico era
quello di chiudersi io ho un brevetto
faccio il prodotto in un modo e non
voglio che non altrove da oggi questo
non funziona più perché se io voglio
capire cosa il mercato propone di nuovo
quali sono le nuove tecnologie che ci
sono nel mercato nella stampante 3d
nonostante o in bottiglia acqua minerale
magari dice ma cosa c'entra la stampante
predico la bottiglia d'acqua minerale
non lo so affinché non mi trovo a
condividere con il mercato con chi fa la
stampante con la stampante 3d la mia
azienda e la sua azienda non so neanche
non saprò mai se c'è la possibilità di
fare una connessione quindi aprirsi per
far entrare tutto quello che è
l'innovazione implica anche aprirsi per
far uscire tutto quello che abbiamo
all'interno dell'azienda
questo difficilissimo per gli
imprenditori italiani perché veramente
siamo ancora nel dire ho paura che
qualcuno mi copy il mondo si è evoluto
grazie alla coppia limitazione no perché
limitazione a voler far finta di essere
un altro ma la copia è il modo in cui il
mondo cresce io vedo una cosa che
posiziona la coppia facendo la mia e
cerco di migliorarla
l'apertura è veramente insieme a mettere
le persone al centro il fattore
determinante nelle aziende del futuro e
l'apertura e soprattutto in mano e
ragazzi giovani perché gli esperti sono
persone chiusissime se io devo far
venire qualcuno nella mia azienda
questo è un consulente venderà
sicuramente uno quali sono le tue
negatività concentrati su quale per
risolverli due le persone le devi
controllare perché se tu dall'altro
decidi che cosa vuoi
le persone devono fare quello che dici
tu quindi il contrario è quello che io
penso cioè il fatto che le persone
devono avere l'autonomia di poter
decidere da soli cosa fare e proprio
perché la messa al centro se mi arriva
un ragazzo di 20 anni che non sa niente
del mio mercato facilmente mi fa
innovazione perché vede quelle cose che
non vede l'esperto a quel apertura
mentale che gli permette di uno non aver
paura di sbagliare tanto al principiante
due vive la realtà dell'evoluzione
l'esperto sicuramente ha vissuto il
mondo statico in cui lui ha studiato
tutto e sa tutto del mercato delle acque
minerali e quindi mi verrà a dire le
cose che sanno anche i miei competitor
se faccio entrare un ragazzo chiaramente
aperta chi ha la voglia di fare che non
ha paura di sbagliare
allora quel punto può fare la differenza
della mia azienda
quindi la cosa veramente che farà sempre
di più la differenza è la capacità
dell'azienda di essere umile aprendosi
le idee degli altri
aprendosi alle idee dei giovani una cosa
che a me questo momento fa molto male è
vedere questa classe di giovani che non
crede più in se stessa ma perché noi
esperti gli diciamo che tanto loro non
sanno niente non potranno cambiare tutto
quello che si è parlato oggi tre anni fa
non sapevamo cosa fosse loro e la loro
realtà per me qualcosa di voi
grazie
alzando i miei mezzi